oh history dr. Sherwin Nuland in depth
live Sunday at noon on book TV Rose
O'Neil green hail was a spy for the
Confederacy during the u.s Civil War and
Blackmun tells her story in the new
biography Wild Rose this public life's
feature is 40 minutes it is a real
pleasure for me to be back in Chapel
Hill my husband Mike putzel spent eighth
happy years here as an undergraduate it
may actually have been longer but it was
during the 60s and that's all he
remembers but Mike has brought me back
here many times he's introduced me to
some wonderful
North Carolina friends when we spend
every Labor Day with at Emerald Isle
he's introduced me to Eastern North
Carolina barbecue Mike started his
career in the Raleigh Bureau of The
Associated Press and then he moved to
the Washington bureau where he spent
many years as the APS chief White House
correspondent it's where I met him and
it's where I met Walter Mears the APS
Pulitzer prize-winning political
correspondent who has just recently
moved to Chapel Hill with his wife Fran
and as they're going to be adjunct
professors at the journalism school here
so naturally when Peggy Myers invited me
to speak I jumped at the opportunity not
just to please Mike not just to see
Walter and Fran again but also to thank
bill Ferris whom I went to see when I
was in the middle of working on the book
and told him I didn't know if a Joisey
girl could write about the south and he
gave me the assurance that at least he
thought I could I could but the real
reason that I wanted to come to Chapel
Hill and a reason that I have to tell
you is enormous ly important to me is to
thank dr. Jones for his help in what was
the most important discovery that I made
during the course of my research that
Rose Greene how
the Civil War's most colorful Spy uppity
broad went on to become a diplomat and
that she was undoubtedly the first
American woman to negotiate for her
government which in this case was the
Confederate government on foreign soil
having written a biography of Madeleine
Albright who a hundred and forty years
before became the first American
Secretary of State this was a
fascinating discovery for me it was a
real scoop
so dr. Jones this is a heartfelt
thank-you I have learned during some
pretty serious negotiations that he is a
scholar and a gentleman but should you
think that it was an easy negotiation
you would be wrong if any of you thought
that his first reaction when I called
him and asked if I could see the years
and years of research that he did he
said oh and I would be delighted you
would have to think again but I'm
getting ahead of my story then there's
another important reason that I'm happy
to be back here in North Carolina and
that's because much of the drama of Wild
Rose unfolds here in the summer of 1863
Rose Greenhow made a mad dash through
the Yankee gunboats blockading the Cape
Fear River and it was there one year
later on her fateful journey home from
Europe that her sleek new blockade
runner ran aground on the shoals off
Fort Fisher dodging fire from Union
blockade errs rose drowned and she was
buried with full military honors at
Oakdale Cemetery in Wilmington let me
back up and tell you a little bit about
Rose Greene how and why I hope that
people will pay more attention to her
for a hundred and forty years she was a
little more than a footnote in history
she was a woman who spied for the south
she was jailed for 10 months by
President Lincoln and then she was
exiled to the south and she died a
dramatic death at sea
yet very little else was known about her
when I first started digging into her
background I learned that she was an
extraordinary character she was
beautiful clever outspoken controversial
she was a slave owner and elitist a snob
not particularly likable in many ways as
dr. Jones said other women gossiped
about her which is never nice but in the
19th century it was unthinkable what
little has been written about rose in
the past always mentioned that she had
four children but I learned from going
through the newspapers in in Washington
for the 30 years that she lived there
that she actually had eight children
five of whom died in infancy and that
alone told me that she was a woman with
a deep well of sadness and that I wanted
to learn more about her what I found is
for more than three decades spanning ten
presidential administrations Rose Greene
how worked Washington society as a
hostess a lobbyist a strategist and a
presidential confidant she was born on a
small plantation in Montgomery County
which is right outside of Washington and
at that time was very much a part of the
south her father died in 1817
leaving his widow with five daughters
and very little money to support them
eventually rose are eventually the
mother sent rose and another daughter to
Washington to live in her sister's
boarding house that was right across the
street from the Capitol and it's where
congressmen stayed when Congress was in
session it was a wonderful place for the
girls because they were introduced to
Washington society the congressmen who
always left their wives at home they
couldn't afford to bring them to the to
the big city the congressmen would wine
and dine the girls escort them to the
White House to diplomatic functions and
the girls got a real sense of what
Washington society was like and it
played a huge role in their upbringing
Rose was also very friendly with John
Calhoun
I think she probably first met him
through Calvin's daughter who was about
the same age and in Calhoun who was a
great supporter of slavery became a
great influence in Rosa's life Rose
married Robert Greene how a
well-traveled physician from a wealthy
Virginia family her sister married
dolley Madison's favorite nephew which
secured them another place in Washington
society when Rose married Robert Greene
how he was the librarian and translator
at the State Department which at that
time was the number three position and
that was the third element in her life
that really brought her into Washington
society then as now you need an entree
and Dolly Madison had provided the bort
life at the boardinghouse had provided
it and Robert Greenhow provided it Rose
was an ambitious lady she was much more
ambitious than her husband Robert who
was in fact rather boring and she became
a master player at the Washington in the
Washington Power game she was very good
friends with or she cultivated the
friendship of James Buchanan who was
Secretary of State
her husband's boss and she would invite
him to dinner parties and sit her
husband next to him and she once wrote
him a letter saying that she knew her
husband would like to be sent to Mexico
City but she thought Italy would be more
fun can any of the men here
imagine what how you would feel if your
wife wrote a letter to your boss
suggesting a different transfer Rose was
adventurous she was nervy and she was
very strong like few women of her time
she participated in the nascent
Nations divisive struggles over slavery
westward expansion and the war with
Mexico when her husband grew depressed
over his constant struggles with a
bureaucracy
and I can assure you they were no
different than than they
right now he quit his job and they went
to California for the gold rush Rose
returned to Washington a year later
traveling alone through the jungles of
Panama and this was a time when travel
was obviously a great deal more
difficult than it is now in fact I think
you could say that rose and Robert had
what today we would consider a commuter
marriage in 1854 Robert Greenhow died in
an accident in San Francisco
leaving Rose with three daughters and
pregnant with a fourth the last child
she named Rose after herself and little
Rose would become her constant companion
as war loomed mrs. green Hao ran
aspiring out of her house on 16th Street
just two blocks from the White House on
July 10th 1861
she sent a coded message to Confederate
general Beauregard that the Union Army
would attack him in a week
this gave Beauregard time to call in
reinforcements and win the Battle of
Bull Run which was the first major
battle of the Civil War famed detective
Allan Pinkerton and his men spent weeks
and months trying to decode her wink her
secret dispatches at one point
Beauregard sent at one point Rose sent
Beauregard a map of Alexandria showing
the defenses that the Union Army had
thrown up to protect the city over the
years some historians mostly men have
said that Rose was not all that
important to the Battle of Bull Run that
Beauregard would have won it without her
but the Confederates general himself
credited Rose with the victory and
Lincoln considered her dangerous enough
to have her put under house arrest her
own memoir of her life under house
arrest corresponds very much with
Pinkertons account I compared the two
and I was surprised at how both loved to
exaggerate they were they the details
and the fact
of what they told were quite similar
Pinkertons own account of how we staked
at her house reads like a scene out of
the Keystone Cops standing in the
pouring rain
he took off his shoes and climbed on the
shoulders of another detective and
peered through the blinds in her window
he saw a Union Army officer come in the
door take her hand
show her a map and then walk arm-in-arm
with her into another room an hour later
they came back looked at another map and
and Pinkerton heard them kiss goodnight
the officer took off down the street and
Pinkertons still in his bare feet took
off after him the officers it's pouring
rain the officer started running he
disappeared into the union headquarters
and Pinkerton the Union man in charge of
finding the officer another Union
soldier went right in after him they
didn't recognize the Union officers
didn't recognize Pinkerton who was their
chief of Secret Service because they
hadn't seen pictures of him before in
the newspapers on CNN the way we do
today so they locked him up put him in
jail overnight and it wasn't until he
gave secret messages to a guard that he
got out a key question of course is how
did rose obtain the Union Army's secrets
and there are several theories Pinkerton
of course thinks it's from the officer
that he saw in his house another theory
is that Senator Henry Wilson of
Massachusetts who was chairman of the
Military Affairs Committee provided rose
with key information a packet of love
letters tied with a yellow ribbon
supposedly from Wilson was prominently
displayed on roses desk when she was
arrested and military historians over
the years have always insisted that that
Wilson was was her source as a woman
I was I'm quite convinced that Rose was
setting up Wilson for whatever reason
that if she had burned a lot of papers
that she had in her house before she was
arrested surely if she wanted to she
would have burned the love letters at
least I would have roses house was on
the site of what is now the st. Regis
Hotel at 16th and K Street in Washington
after her arrest Lincoln turned it into
a prison for women women spies and
called it the House of Detention for
female rebels the press dubbed at Fort
Greene how Rose spent five months here
under house arrest and when she kept
getting messages out to the South in her
knitting through bribing guards with
invisible ink Lincoln had her thrown
into the Old Capitol prison the old
Capitol was used by Congress after the
British burned the original Capitol in
the war of 1812
it was later turned in to the boarding
house that rose spent her teenage years
living in this is absolute proof that
that truth is stranger than fiction
sometimes and it was at this boarding
house that Rose returned to nurse her
mentor John Calhoun on his deathbed
it was later turned into a prison it was
turned into a prison early on in the
Civil War by four POWs and people like
Rose who were suspected of disloyalty
Rose kept her daughter little Rose with
her throughout her entire time in jail
and I recently discovered a painting
that's now in the bigs Museum of
American Art in Delaware that shows Rose
and little rose as inmates in May of
1862 five months after Rose had been in
the prison ten months after she'd been
captive five and under house arrest five
in the Old Capitol prison
Lincoln had her exiled and sent south
she and little Rose left Baltimore by
boat arriving at Fort Montreux on June
2nd just as McClellan's army was
slogging up the peninsula towards
Richmond
at Fort Monroe which was still under
Yankee guard they transferred to a small
launch from the from the monitor and
proceeded under a flag of truce for for
City point Rose had a confederate flag
that she had made herself in prison
hidden under her shawl and as her boat
pulled up towards the Confederate land
the promised land as she called it
she thought of unveiling the flag as
kind of a final bye boys to the Yankees
but for once in her life she thought
better of it she was welcomed by colonel
WS Ashe at the dock and a freight train
sent by Jefferson Davis met them and
took them to Richmond Jefferson Davis
considered her a heroine and he came to
her hotel to welcome her the night she
arrived he worked wrote to his wife
Farina who had fled the city with their
children that he was surprised how much
Rose had aged since he had known her
during his years in the Senate in
Washington the madam looks much changed
and has the air of one whose nerves were
shaken he wrote a year later in the
summer of 1863 with the South desperate
for help
Jefferson Davis tapped Rose to be his
personal emissary to Europe
hoping to persuade the British and the
French to recognize the Confederate
government
I asked Civil War historian Jim
McPherson why Davis would send a woman
was this an act of desperation on his
part it was a stroke of genius McPherson
replied not only would Davis not have
worried about sending a woman to Europe
on a diplomatic mission but he would
have been convinced that this particular
woman was the best person for the job
because of her imprisonment in the Union
Basti had invoked indignation and
sympathy abroad
no one knew much about what Rose did in
Europe because she drowned coming home
the ship that was bringing her into
Wilmington which was the last open port
in the Confederacy ran aground as it
entered the Cape Fear River and Rose who
had spent almost a year
Prison demanded to be taken ashore as
her lifeboat was lowered into the water
a wave hit it broadside
knocking everybody overboard the crew
swam back to the ship but Rose had tied
the two thousand dollars in gold coins
that she'd raised for the Confederate
Army in a pouch around her neck
and her body washed up on shore the next
morning at dawn it was found by a
Confederate soldier patrolling the beach
his name was JJ prosper for me dr.
Duvall Conner doc Conner to his friends
and he was three feet 11 inches tall
probably the shortest man in the
Confederate Army which gives you an idea
of how desperate the Confederate Army
was at that point also found on roses
body was a cipher that she had used to
send her messages to Beauregard it would
have saved Pinkerton months of work and
I've actually issued a challenge on the
book website
ww-why Wild Rose book calm for visitors
to crack the code and try and decipher
roses seized messages we've had three
winners so far one is the head of the
white house at the Museum of the
Confederacy in Richmond no one knew that
Rose kept a diary it was left in her
trunk aboard the ship in the trunk with
a diary in it was later sold at auction
in 1965 as you've heard tonight from dr.
Jones more than a century later it was
identified in the North Carolina State
Archives it had been in the papers of
former governor David L Swain and dr.
Jones identified it but as he told you
it was almost illegible in the summer of
2003 almost 40 years later I asked the
North Carolina State Archives to send me
a copy of the diary but when it arrived
I couldn't read a word in it I asked to
professional transcribe
at the archives that they could help me
and they told me it was written in code
which was entirely possible because Rose
sent many of her messages out in code
one told me it would take in a thousand
hours to translate and it couldn't be
done the former editor of the papers of
Jefferson Davis referred me to dr. Jones
mr. North Carolina he called him saying
he might have a copy of the
transcription when I first called
contacted dr. Jones I told him I was
writing a biography of Rose Greene how
and did he know anything about a
transcription of her diary he said he
did he said he had one and I boldly
asked if he would share it with me
proudly telling him that I was a news
reporter it didn't fly I told him it
would add a voice to Rose's manuscript I
know he thought I worked for People
magazine he was very doubtful the news
reporter part really put him off this
was a man who had lived and breathed an
academic life so I was going to have to
prove to him that I was serious the fact
of the matter is I didn't know what he
had I had no idea what was in the diary
and what followed was a series of very
serious negotiations and you can imagine
how pleased and relieved I is I was when
dr. Jones finally agreed to lend me his
transcription and he explained that he
had kept the work secret for almost 40
years because he hoped to have it
annotated and published one day he under
he dr. Jones loaned me the transcription
with some understandings and one was
that I would not copy it that I could
take notes on that copy but I had to
return it to him in a year I agreed and
I couldn't wait to get my hands on it
but when I arrived and I read it I was
terribly disappointed
I'm sure I've never told you that I
could finally read the words but I
didn't know any of the people that she
was talking about Lord Palmerston lady
fulling ttan Thomas Carlyle I was not
familiar with the names that rose
dropped so freely I didn't know the
routes that she traveled I knew nothing
of the history of France and Britain
during the Civil War I had had of hired
a very talented British researcher to
help me but now I was in a bind I
couldn't send her the diary because I'd
promised not to copy it and I didn't so
I sent my researcher a list of the names
and places that rose identified and six
months later Sheila Evans sent me a box
load of thick folders several big boxes
filled with extraordinary descriptions
of every person every home address every
travel route that Rose took she even
unearthed the original book contract
that Rose Greenhow had signed in London
and her research allowed me to piece all
of the pieces of the puzzle together
parts that I hadn't understood were
suddenly coming alive the book contract
for example is the only piece of
information I have this shows that Rose
Greenhow actually Rose O'Neill
greenhouse spelled O'Neill with an e
most people have not spelled it that way
and suddenly following Rose's travels in
her own words the war became alive to me
her first entry was August 5th 1863
after she and little Rose now ten years
old had boarded the blockade er phantom
for the dangerous race to Europe under
fire from Union ships Rose described
going down the Cape Fear River being
shot at by ships as they made a dash
through the Union blockade
she got terribly seasick and
and she had taken lots of cotton that
Jefferson Davis had given her to sell to
pay her way over there the cotton was on
deck and to keep from being violently
ill she would sleep on deck putting her
fingers around the bale of cotton to
keep from falling overboard as the ship
pitched in and and swerved as it was
being shot out the detail in the diary
is absolutely extraordinary
she made the last entry one year later
just before she boarded another blockade
a blockade runner for her faithful giant
for her fateful journey home the diary
is absolutely remarkable when you put
the names and the faces together Rose
had negotiations with Napoleon the third
and Twitter reap Alice which he
describes in great detail she had
arguments with the British prime
minister the Lord Palmerston whose name
I hadn't recognized arguing with him but
that he recognized the South that he
send them arms that he send them ships
she talked with the aristocrats and the
society people at the highest levels of
British aristocracy and French
aristocracy she even considered going to
see the Pope in Rome with a secret peace
plan for ending the war and she wrote
all of these details to Jefferson Davis
and long 14:16 page letters that are
absolutely remarkable I'm still a news
reporter at heart and the diary when I
finally understood it was an amazing
scoop it shows Rose was much more
important to American history and
particularly to Confederate history than
anyone knew and I found that you don't
have to be a southerner and you don't
have to share her politics to understand
that Rose was a woman of courage and
convictions who took risks she took
enormous risks for the cause that she
believed in and like thousands of
thousands of soldiers on both the north
and the south
she was willing to die for her cause and
she did so dr. Jones this is really your
scoop and I thank you for sharing it
with me thank you
[Applause]
anybody have any questions anybody have
to run this is your time to her daughter
that's a very good question mr. Johnson
and I want you all to know that this
question was asked by a man who wrote a
book about Rose O'Neal greenhouse and
the blockade runners many many years
before I ever heard of her
and he's one of the few scholars in
history to have spelled O'Neill
correctly so I will the life of her
daughter's is is really interesting her
oldest daughter Florence married a Union
soldier before the war he was a he was a
soldier before the war he joined the
Union Army he fought for the Army in
Ohio and he actually after roses husband
died he actually helped support rose and
she went and and begged the Union
officials to give him promotions which
had to kill her because it had to be a
very difficult personal situation for
him
little Rose went to Europe with her
mother and Rose enrolled her in a
convent in Paris which is now the site
of the Rodin Museum and I actually got
the the notes from the convent from a
nun who was an historian in Paris and
they had that little roses records of
her in the school there and and winner
and it was written that when she heard
that her mother died she sobbed and
sobbed and she was inconsolable and she
asked if she could be baptized because
she could better pray for her mother and
that the top Catholic in France came and
baptized her and it was interesting to
me that she hadn't been baptized because
Rose had been born a Catholic but I also
learned
in the course of the diary of reading
the diary that rose although she had
been born a Catholic had never been
baptized herself and she was baptized by
the top Catholic priest in Britain and
all of Europe in fact so and then little
rose eventually came back married a an
army officer had a child got divorced
and I never found any living relatives
who could tell me anything about them
but I'm hoping that things will turn up
now on the web is more people hear about
her and more people are looking into
their backgrounds the other questions
yes
would you like to ask that into the
microphone as we have yeah no what was
the history of the whole evil family
prior to Rose and when did they come to
over to America they came in in the 16
and 1700s came to Virginia and Maryland
one of the really interesting things I
found about her father is Rose had
always grown up being told that her
father was killed by his slave and what
I found in going through the trial of
the slave and I didn't even know that
they had trials for slaves was that her
father had spent a day at a local tavern
gotten roaring drunk came home late at
night in a bad storm fell off his horse
and hit his head on a rock and his slave
went for help when the slave came back
he was arrested convicted of murder and
hanged in Rockville and as a result of
learning that slavery became a sub theme
of the book slavery as it unfolded in
Washington during the war and you know
one of the things I tried to do is just
lay out the story as I found it and not
subscribe any motives to rose or or try
and think how she might have felt at any
time as a news reporter I've been
trained not to do that so you can only
wonder if having thought all of her life
that her father was murdered by his
slave that affected her feelings about
slavery I'll let you draw your own
conclusions on that anyone else
the details about her her death I've
heard other stories that she had been
robbed by the seamen there were on the
on the boat that she was trying to reach
land with where'd you get the details of
her death what source well I got them
from a number of places one is I found
the diary of Colonel lamb who was the
head of the Fort Fisher at the time and
the body was brought to him I'll also
have the diary of the family of Doc
Conner the the the man who the
Confederate soldier who found her and as
I pieced them both together it appears
that the Confederate soldier who found
her saw the gold and and wanted to take
it and in fact did and then immediately
felt guilty or thought he might be
caught you don't know what he felt but
but whatever he thought he put it back
and dug a little hole and made it look
like the waves had come over it and
pointed out his discovery to Colonel
lamb who rewarded him with one silver or
one gold coin and one of the things I've
done throughout the book is because I'm
not a historian and I don't pretend to
have a great deal of background on the
Civil War as I've taken every chapter of
the book to the best people I could find
in the country to read them for me and
to go over them and those chapters I had
Chris Vaughn Vey at who was a civil war
historian at UNC Wilmington who who
helped me in in those matters
I had Stephen wises the blockade expert
in the United States read the blockade
chapters I had the Buchanan expert in
the United States read the chapters on
James Buchanan and I had the US the
Senate historian Don Richie read the
first 11 chapters of the book about the
first the early history of the war so
they're they're probably some factual
errors there but some of the experts
didn't catch them
other questions yes sir
you tell us it's more a reference to it
I think Rose probably met Calhoun
through his daughter Rose liked to hang
out in the Senate press gal or the
Senate gallery in the house gallery and
in the Supreme Court as many of the
ladies of the day did listening to the
arguments of what was going on it was a
place to socialize it was a place to be
educated as many of the women didn't go
to school but they learned about the
issues of the day and I think Rose
admired Calhoun I know that during some
years he stayed at the boarding house
that her aunt ran not certainly not all
of the years that she was there but he
became a friend of her family he became
a very good friend of her husband and
and her husband worked for at Calhoun
during some of his when he ran for
various offices when he ran for
president and I think it was just a
family friendship over the years yes
Walter why did you become interested in
this woman well when I did the biography
of metal and Albright it was Minh many
ways a difficult book to do she played
real hardball with me and and in the end
she didn't give me any interviews until
the week the book was due and I was a
nervous wreck and everybody whom I
talked to on the Albright book had a
motive to talk to me either they wanted
to please Madeleine by saying something
nice they wanted to anonymously say
something nasty about her there was all
of the politics that we have in
Washington when you do interviews with
it with important people so in the last
interview I had with Albright and we had
fabulous long wonderful interviews that
she loved and I
probably the best I've ever had in my
life she stood on her front porch in
Georgetown she put her hands on her hips
and she said so and who are you gonna
write about next and I said madam
secretary I don't have a clue but she's
going to be long dead I meant it as a
joke
she laughed I laughed it's what Mike's
mother called kidding on the level but
then I was looking around for somebody
to write about and I then wrote about
Robert Hansen who wasn't dead but I
hadn't in mind that I wanted to explore
the life of some powerful person
preferably a woman because I've been
interested in women in Washington and
have written about an awful lot of them
and I read an article in The Washington
Post about rose greenhouse and it
interested me
I had it took me a long time to decide
to commit myself to a book on her
because I was terrified that I couldn't
find any original information there
really wasn't much out there but finally
I I sort of signed the contract bit the
bullet and with Mike's constant
encouragement and constantly telling me
that if you look hard enough you will
find new things I was pleasantly
surprised that I did yes did mrs. green
have any difficult to get in the
audience with the aristocrats of all
Europe oh they loved her I mean she was
just the person to send over because she
was not an official official she was not
the French ambassador the British
ambassador and she could just flip
between them and she was beautiful and
she was charming and she was very
knowledgeable she was very much like
Pamela Harriman steeped in democratic
politics a lobbyist a hostess traveled
easily between northerners and
southerners in want in Washington and
the French and the British in Europe
she spoke good French I was sort of
amazed in her diary
as she writes it out herself her French
was was almost flawless and when she was
talking to Napoleon she began speaking
to him in English and he said that he
understood she spoke French and she said
well she understood that he spoke
perfect English and I mean the
negotiations are fatter absolutely
fabulous and so I guess that's the long
answer for know people love to see her
she was controversial and you know caddy
and and smart anyone else have questions
dr. Jones
roses effects and sold them over and
wrong at auction he was one of the
swains agents around the state Swain was
collecting manuscripts around all over
North Carolina and he had contacts
throughout the state and Wright was a
very close friend of his yes sir
in the women's prison for Confederate
rebels all competitive no well who were
some of the other women that were there
in the prison with her you know you're
gonna put me on the spot because I'm not
sure I can recall their names right off
there's no one that you would have heard
of necessarily they were mostly the
wives of southern politicians who were
in roses spiring who who came in and
they actually lived in different rooms
of the houses of her house and there
were guards all over protecting them and
spying on them and they'd bring a women
woman guard in to frisk them
and roses other friends who were not
prisoners were allowed to come and go
Rose even had a gun I mean she even had
a gun in prison which is maybe that's
not so unusual yes crazy bet rose no no
Belle Boyd was not there Belle Boyd was
in the Old Capitol prison after rose was
there they may they probably knew each
other but they weren't in prison at the
same time anyone else
well thank you all very much for coming
[Applause]
and Blackman has written biographies of
Madeleine Albright and Robert Hanssen
her latest Wild Rose rose of Neil
greenhouse Civil War Spy is published by
Random House on the web at Random House
dot-com